thank you
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
creek in the cave give it up for
yourselves for coming out here tonight
we have a great show for you guys this
is just a quick reminder to please keep
table talk to a minimum avoid looking at
your cell phones and please do not
Heckle the people on stage now without
further Ado give it up for your host of
the evening the host of other people
Hans can't everybody
at other people a show about dating
which is something that I'm pretty good
at uh can we get more lights on the
stage as many lights as possible just
light this [__] up we're gonna
have a great show uh you know I just
caught in from Seattle
so it's good to be in a good American
city not one of those liberal hellholes
just kidding Austin's a liberal hell
um but yes we have a great guest tonight
hopefully she's ready but if not I can
keep stalling oh there she is uh very
funny from New York City which is also a
liberal hell hole it's very funny it's
Gina hyena
[Music]
Gina hyena hey how are you this Sunday
I'm good and I thought we were gonna
have a table in front of us so I might
flash [__] on accident oh [__] or I'm
welcome hmm
it's a free show
that you paid for right
now I'm doing good and that was wild
because I just saw Hans outside and he
was like are you ready and I was like
yeah I got to use the bathroom and he's
like cool okay I'll be right in and then
I heard him from the bathroom starting
the show but I'm doing well how you been
that's great um I've been good I uh
that's always a nervous time as a
performer when you're in the bathroom
Panic shooting
well luckily we're here
um everything worked out perfectly
perfectly how's the uh the old dating
scene in New York I just started dating
again so I got a really logical guy and
then I got a guy who's skateboards well
you got options I'm more excited about
the guy who skateboards
I'm 36.
[Music]
[Laughter]
some laughs of recognition in the
audience
hell yeah she's gonna do an ollie in
your [__] yeah I can't wait for him to
nose grind
oh yeah
well we're gonna get some dates coming
up here we even got an LGBT person
kind of cool hopefully you're asexual
because there's only one of you in there
we got a bunch of dudes let's get a dude
up here we're gonna do a little
interview for him and then we're gonna
do 90 seconds of dating and then we're
gonna interview you again so this first
guy coming up is ooh we got Justin Cox
coming to the stage Justin Cox Justin
Cox
that sounds like a [__] prank call
name
[Laughter]
that's a gay guy that doesn't [__] butts
but [__] Tristan Cox just only Cox for
Justin
nice to meet you Justin ask him
we were talking [__] about you just a
second ago I don't know if you heard it
but now you got tattoos just uh just a
tad big bicep so we're gonna chill out
on the making fun of how's the uh dating
scene
uh it's uh that's non-existent but it's
uh it's just starting yeah are you
religious or are you just
got a sick tiger tattoo yeah I know yeah
not very religious at all but uh
definitely a little spiritual hell yeah
oh the spiritual guys
what a treat sorry what a [__] I'm
sorry
it's hard to explain
um how do you like to uh go to Zilker
Park what do you wear when you go to
Zilker Park just nothing or
things happen like shorts and a hula
hoop and uh does your T-shirt say
firings
I almost says sinner like sinner like
you hate Jesus no no not at all just
that sinner like we sin yeah it's Austin
so
a lot of that going on why are you not
getting [__] dude
[Music]
we got a demon on the stage
I don't really go out very much I I just
work a lot man just kind of chill at the
house so
working on not getting [__] maybe you
should start dating Jesus
well uh you're a very handsome man
beautiful beautiful man with beautiful a
beautiful body
it needs a lot of work I think you
should go out there and get laid dude
don't let Jesus tell you who to [__]
Jesus and change your shirt coming
together
we have Jesus Christ
Jesus's number one disciple Justin Cox
he sucks [__] for Jesus
he said oh boy
she'll be nice Jesus tattoos on me I
don't know if I can say all that stuff
so like I said I believe Jesus tattoos
on you and a t-shirt that says sinner
yeah I'm a little uh perplexed oh so
whoever at least we know he doesn't have
like any like what's the word you finish
the joke baggage yeah Flags
Hang-Ups what's the thing where you
actually are like oh commitment issues
hey oh hey you got Jesus tattoos and a
sinner t-shirt sounds like this guy's
got commitment issues that's what I
wanted to do that sounds better when you
said it all together yeah yeah yeah I'm
kind of all over the place
oh this girl has to be nicer to you than
us which is going to be easy
this guy's heart's already taken by
Jesus let's see if this woman can also
find her way into his heart
and
love him
commitment issues is that a password we
got Shauna coming up a woman named
Shawna Shawna get on up here
Shawna keep it going for Shawna it feels
better when you
it feels better when you walk on the
stage to clapping there she comes yeah
[Applause]
oh I like this already this is cute
yes ma'am like a fist away from your
mouth
oh is it dead
all right okay cool
okay
hello and start dating the Jesus Freak
right now 90 seconds go all right so
what was your name again
where are you from China
originally Iran Virginia
when did you move here
to Austin never I don't live here so
you're just visiting I'm visiting yeah
okay yeah it's it's been it's cool so
where do you currently stay
oh well around let's I mean let's just
take it easy yeah I don't want you to
have my address quite yet but we're not
no no yeah no need for an address yeah
stay like in the Texas area you're just
visiting coming visiting yeah yeah East
Coast Virginia East Coast okay yeah East
Coast love yeah wow yeah a lot of the
East Coast people here now a lot of West
Coast people here now yeah that I have
heard yes not a whole lot of people from
here here you know what I mean so yes I
don't know where the East Coast person
they've gone somewhere so what part of
East Coast New York Virginia yep in the
middle of the middle middle okay I said
this you don't pay attention so yeah I'm
hard to hear him so honestly some
negative points we're going in one out
the other side okay I got it all up here
it's okay good heck yeah heck yeah you
go to the beach a lot what do you like
to do for fun um I go to the beach uh
sometimes yeah I live at the Beach I
mean I don't live at the beach I live at
a place called Virginia Beach that has a
beach that I sometimes go to sometimes
that was a convoluted answer okay cool
cool what's your favorite part about
Texas what do you like in here
everything's bigger I heard so there's
that's funny I don't understand what
that means everybody says everything's
bigger in Texas but I don't know what's
bigger in Texas and Time Justin
give it up for Justin and Shauna
[Applause]
Justin just admits he has a small penis
and Shauna is from where
Iran
where where in Iran is Virginia
[Laughter]
I'm having a hard time pinpointing this
this is great this is an Iranian and an
American going on a date is a preview of
world war three coming up
we got some nukes flying
you said you don't know you you don't
have a permanent address you know he
should have been able to tell with those
earrings
very free-spirited
is that your natural hair color it is it
is my natural that's beautiful lack of
hair color
it's just not I gave up a minority's
dream turning white thank you yeah
I said it's a minority's dream to turn
white you're turning white
starting
back face here yeah pretty white
[Music]
hell yeah Shawna what brought your
parents over to the great country of
America
uh mostly not wanting to be in Iran
mostly the drone strikes
the hijab stuff and all the stuff
they're going through oh yeah so yeah uh
Justin what's uh something that you
could tell Shawna about Texas that might
surprise her
don't mention size again
you've been to the Crosby Springs
no is that like the the sadot look
no it's just like a beautiful spring
place I don't know we have like some of
the best Springs here that's the only
thing I'd say about Texas if you haven't
been here are you inviting are you is
that I mean I was gonna say I got a
tight schedule but uh okay well then you
know
all right I squeeze something in you
never know he's got to go to church
[Music]
uh Justin where are you from
I'm from here Austin Texas yeah yeah
that's where the commitment issues came
from commitment issues guy right guys
wait wait so what is your type usually
uh let's ask Shauna is it Shawna yeah
what's your type usually
uh uh people with issues and problems oh
psycho sociopaths welcome to every icon
that he has on him right now basically
basically confuse people
um
a lot of liars uh those are a lot of
those down here yeah I mean pretty
prevalent
so you're in the right place on Sixth
Street too yeah I'm glad good
Justin what's your type
um honestly just more personality
somebody's hard working ambitious
somebody who you know wants to actually
settle down and kind of do something
um
are you working are you uh looking for a
day labor or a wife
yeah I need a we kind of need more work
you need someone to fix your plumbing
dedicated hard working wants to come
home and fix everything Justin what do
you do for work
uh so just keep the microphone up honey
so I just I just got out of the military
and they moved back here and I was just
oh [__] it's a military guy give it up
for Justin he served the country
I didn't get that part
icular Sean family
doing a tour over there
I was in the I was in the Coast Guard so
I stationed in Florida I just dealt with
like this Cubans not Iranians I was I
was with Cubans and all of them yes
Iranians they were on those were the
Marines and the armies guys we were here
at home dealing with uh Southerners so
well thank you for committing war crimes
near us
yeah
Coast Guard that's cool were you just
feeding the kids in cages is that what
you were doing
it's pretty much throwing some Pop-Tarts
yeah yeah waving around my citizenship
card you know oh y'all could have been
wow what an [__]
I mean just my type right here
[Laughter]
would you guys go on a second date
uh well I'm actually here with a date so
I don't really think I can say that wow
commitment issues guy am I right
well then he's on a day with Jesus
right on yeah right so Sean is down for
the second date I mean usually I don't
know about it till later so yeah I mean
this is good you're upfront about it so
yeah look at the change okay okay this
is great it's uh looks like it's either
a date or Justin's about to get his
fortune read if you guys want to like
hopefully after an exchange Instagram
sorry it's a back room there I don't
think she'll know
I think we're being really discreet
real quick like as we're walking down
have you ever dated an American white
before
away yes yeah she said Liars
what do you notice about the whites
dating them that maybe
lack of melanin a lot of sunblock you
guys lather sunblock on each other
[Music]
music choices and and 311 or lack of
have you ever had a white guy try to
cook you food
lack of seasoning I hide
my seasoning cabinet is filled I'm
offended what was that so my seasoning
cabinet is filled I'm offended I'm not
seasoned around here okay so you got
five types of salt he's like I got the
pink salt I got the rock salt the garlic
salt all-purpose seasoning salt
[Laughter]
what's your favorite seasoning Justin
all-purpose seasoning salt I'll put that
on everything
what a sophisticated gentleman
he confiscated some adobo at the border
all his seasonings are from [__]
taking them at the border
Cuban seasoning
all those Cuban tears he's been milking
yeah that's awesome he probably got that
at HEB if I'm not mistaken
absolutely yeah I just got back um
earlier for a shopping trip I just spent
way Shawna what was the last date that
you went on
oh well
It's been a long time
um the last date I didn't go on let's
answer it that way it was uh act
throwing I didn't know because you know
PTSD well
you never know somebody could
yeah yeah yeah a guy inviting you to ax
throwing on a first date is like a real
bad move no yeah don't invite us to go
ax throwing anywhere with weapons or
hiking that's how girls go missing
after a hike or in the middle of a hike
yeah during yeah yeah right always bad
yeah don't remember the last date I
maybe it was pre-coveted oh [__] really
yeah oh okay we gotta keep your name to
the side pre-covered yeah did you get
coveted and your [__] dried up or
something
Asian
and you better joke than that about
I'm sorry
what was it about covet though people's
mouths you know so I'm like I you don't
want to go out without kissing someone's
mouth and their covety mouth and yeah
just kind of yeah yeah in Austin they
just have herpes so
yeah so yeah was it a white guy that
asked you to go ax throwing or was it
obviously I mean I wanted to ask you a
bunch of questions yeah it wasn't a
black guy
was it a black guy that wanted to ask
you questions uh that's cool so uh what
do you think Justin likes to do on a
date besides listen to Coldplay
definitely
I've actually never been outstanding
before but I would totally be down to do
ax Stone yeah all right
here there's like smash rooms too we can
break a bunch of stuff like that come on
you can't you can't tell me that one you
guys ever go to a break room and listen
to Limp Bizkit it's like pretty sick
I'm telling you I'm telling you
all right should we get some more people
okay let's get another couple you guys
were awesome thank you thank you for
coming Shawna so fun giving up for
Shawna and Justin everybody
let's get a woman up here
Lana Lana
Lana or Iana
give it for Lana more
is that Justin's date that's coming up
on stage [__] yeah
[__] yeah Lana or Ianna
okay microphone like a fitted from your
mouth cool yeah pretend it's Justin's
huge ego last name
are you here with Justin or is he here
is who's that other person there with
her
and his like situationship and then we
have me and Justin is this off the mic
is off
yeah so we have um my brother and then
his situation ship is complicated and
then me and Justin cool cool fun table
nice that's what hot people do they just
have situationships well it's actually
funny no offense I just take whatever I
can get yeah well so Brian's my brother
and I met Salia me and her had like made
out and everything and then now her and
my brother are dating so it's okay let's
see it again come on up here we're gonna
watch you guys make out for 30 minutes
brother your brother saw his sister make
out with somebody he was like hot I
should date that girl he didn't see it
but he saw it on social media and then
he was like yeah let me date that one
God damn I'm like kids these days in
[__] Indiana you guys are all
perverts
you guys are Snapchatting
oh that's wild
that's crazy you guys are thinner the
whole table up here you guys are going
to hell
[__] crazy
oh my God so if you make out with your
date on the table here is your brother
gonna date them too I can only hope so
if they're a nice guy right it doesn't
say it's about personality so I think at
this point you know it could work
[__] yeah Miss rules let's just make fun
of Justin because
it's [__] rules
all right
how did you meet Justin
um I actually knew him from like years
ago
um and then just randomly from trying to
cross the border
decide so like hey
like and then where was the first
hangout uh
was it like a roller skating rink or
something
what do we do I don't know we just went
out to dinner I
yeah like Chick-fil-A where'd you go no
it was like
Zanzibar that's what it was he's like I
remember every moment
[Laughter]
she's like he's one of the 17 people I
made out with that day
your mic's off again
why aren't we Whispering
all right cool who's who's she gonna go
on a date with so what what is what is
it about that lady that want you wanted
to make out with that lady with her
miss me oh you like that she couldn't
resist you a little bit oh that's cool
narcissism rules
[Laughter]
don't tell men that
oh no
[Music]
I fixed it
power of a hand yeah Philip Guarino
one of the names watch out for Justin on
your way up here keep it going for
Phillip Phillip Guarino
he's wearing a shirt that's made for
dating ooh
dressed to impress
we got our PA Nick Roche oh yeah save
the day give it up for Nick nice to
watch a white guy be the I.T guy for an
Asian guy that's pretty cool
the roles have reversed
I'm Phil tablecloth oh we got somebody
OCD in the audience what's wrong having
a bad time now is that better there we
go all right 90 seconds between Philip
and Lana starting now
you doing so I'm a little tired
red flags I got like abandonment issues
all right I mean my mom don't get along
you know so like a little bit of mommy
issues you know but I love it sometimes
it's
well sometimes
yeah red flag off the top throw it at me
I'm gonna Gaslight you duh
all right all right and so what what
makes you stand out from anybody out
here what doesn't make me stand out I
guess you're right
but it was funny they're just talking
about it guy right you guys are saying
I'm an I.T guy so that's pretty
coincidental uh don't tell me that hey I
make bread my dad's an Asian I.T guy
okay I'm not Asian though you know I'm
Italian
oh so you're a walking red flag some
Italians hey there's nothing wrong with
those Italians we know how to get it
done
but uh so what's your favorite color
favorite color by far yellow
I uh I look good in yellow
you don't like a little bit of brown
do what you don't like a little bit of
brown tan no I mean I don't feel like I
I don't feel like I could rock it like
that oh I guess we're not a match then
so I guess a state hey
ouch close she just closed before like
90 seconds was up that was wild he said
he could we would he couldn't rock it
I can't see myself all right all right
Redemption go and time give it up for
Lana and
Philip Phil
great job guys you guys really proved
that hey give it up for that it's an
Ideal breaker that toxicity oh my God
Lana your STEEZ is [__] crazy that
was wild I also like that she said what
doesn't make me stand out to you is if
she's not a girl at flash tattoos and
athleisure in [__] Austin you're not
wrong about that
Phil is pretending like he would not
just say yes to anything
or hear you say
you say
I'm Italian I know my people
I got deep
you know people aren't really that
thrilled about Italians you act like
it's such a big deal
what's wrong because it's Italian hey
what's wrong with the Italians they just
sort of whatever
um you said red flags you didn't say
anything about green white and red flags
I already got that on my neck
where are you from Sicily oh [__] you're
you're a new one well I mean my family
moved here when I was three oh okay
yeah that's right Italians sound pretty
when they talk
yeah only when they speak Italian though
yeah what happens when you speak English
we just sound gross what are you doing
get out of here hey
they think it's all a joke
[Music]
something about this guy something about
this guy I like like I think it's the
Italian of me hey
this rules
yeah now we got two half Asians and Two
Italians on the stage should we just
fight yeah